Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Earlier we had an episode about OpenAI's absolutely
amazing algorithm that mastered DOTA 2, a
competitive online battle arena game, and
managed to beat some of the best players in
the world in a relatively limited 1 versus
1 game mode.
While the full 5 versus 5 version of this
learning algorithm is still in the works,
scientists at OpenAI experimented with some
self-play in other games and have found some
remarkable results.
You can see here that most of these amusing
experiments take place in a made up 3D game
with simulated physics.
For instance, performing well with these humanoid
creatures means controlling 17 actuated joints
properly.
These agents use a reinforcement learning
algorithm to maximize a reward, for instance,
a sumo warrior gets a thousand points for
pushing their opponent out of the ring.
The first interesting thing is that a learning
curriculum was used, which means that the
algorithm was allowed to explore on their
own by relaxing the strict scores that are
given only when winning.
This is combined with the fact that these
agents play against themselves led to some
remarkable emergent behaviors.
Here you can see with the score how much of
a difference this curriculum makes, and you
also see that whenever a plot is symmetric
that means that they are zero-sum games, so
if one agent wins a given number of points,
the other loses the same amount.
The self-play part is also particularly interesting
as many agents are being trained in parallel
at the same time, and if we're talking about
one versus one games, we have to create some
useful logic to decide who to pair with whom.
It seems that training against an older version
of a previously challenged opponent was the
best strategy.
This makes sense because they are running
a similar algorithm, and for self-play, this
means that the algorithm is asked to defeat
an older version of itself.
If it can reliably do that, it will lead to
a smooth and predictable learning process.
It is kinda incredible to think about the
fact that we have a virtual world with a bunch
of simulated learning creatures and we are
omnipotent beings trying to craft the optimal
learning experience for them.
The perks of being a researcher in machine
learning.
And we are even being paid for this!
Isn't this incredible?
Psst, don't tell anyone about this.
There are so many interesting results here
and so much to talk about.
For instance, we haven't even talked about
transfer learning, where these creatures learn
to generalize their knowledge learned from
previous tasks to tackle new challenges more
efficiently.
Make sure to have a look at the paper, and
the source code is available for everyone
free of charge.
If you are one of those fellow tinkerers,
you'll be more than happy to look into the
video description.
If you wish to hear more about transfer learning,
subscribe and turn on notifications because
the next episode is going to about some really
cool results in this area.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!